let's do it right now uh so happy Cheers
that's why is it bad that this is making
me want to drink that
[Music]
hey I'm Sophia Lacey with ET and here we
are doing an interview under the
influence with Hanson I am so excited
you guys and I can't even actually
pretend to have any chill you guys were
my first album than I ever had I had it
on cassette and CD die-hard fan for a
very very long time
[Music]
20:17 was a huge year your friends the
tour the greatest hits album the
Christmas album
we've been going nonstop since 92
practically when we started but but this
is our 25th anniversary being abandoned
and so we've been touring all over the
world and that's been amazing but we
also we've warmed up for it though
because the last couple years we paused
for a second started a little beer
company so we thought this was we knew
this was going to be a busy year for
music and Tori
[Music]
two decades in the business and you guys
still get Fant like crazy fan reactions
like hormonal teenager level fan
reactions and this was honestly the most
nervous I've ever been preparing for an
interview in my life just because I
think you're doing very very well
oh that would be recommended drinking
yes myself no but I mean you guys I
think have dealt with it so graciously
over the years and and that's gotta be
hard for you being as young as you were
we got into this because it what we're
pursuing and anything the heart of doing
something for a long time is really
knowing why you're doing in the first
place and in our case we were always
doing it for ourselves right doing it
for our own Drive and I think kind of
concede it it's nothing more that you
know where you're centering you and so
it is extremely flattering to have
people enthusiastic and of course as a
young guy of course like a bunch of
girls screaming is not a bad thing to be
honest though I think it would have to
be really hard on your wives to put in
that position initially when you ball
first started dating right they struggle
with all the screaming girls well no
they're all like we won why isn't some
form another at shows Wow
you know that there are fans to a degree
I mean we better be fans otherwise
they'd be nuts they'd go crazy like you
have to appreciate what you know thank
goodness we were in a band because I
would have never ever found a wife it's
still amazing it's not amiss I will go
round and round
alright let's get into the game let's
get to some real dirt here okay so we're
going to be playing truth or drink I'm
gonna ask you guys a series of questions
if you answer I will drink and if you
want to plead the fifth and not answer
then you all will drink and today we are
gonna be drinking your signature beer
yes pop this is our pale ale yeah
everybody so in who does exist in 2013
we officially started have two brothers
beer compete
this refers to the truth I live in
information to say but I will drink
first
so I'm happily married but many years
ago I had big plans of being Zacks wife
so cheers to that 7.5 percent alcohol
worth quick yeah here we go okay have
you ever written a song while tipsy or
drunk and have we ever heard it alcohol
has definitely influenced some music
let's be honest that vocals what drunk
absolutely I would say there are songs
that have been written while drinking
but I don't know if a full drunk usually
kills this something yeah I think you
have said yeah yeah I will drink or you
know we call drink together that's fine
it's a win-win you guys tell me the most
cringe-worthy encounter you've ever had
with a fan that's like right now when
she told me that she wanted to marry me
a million years ago pretty crazy you can
throw you're gonna drink to not up to
not answer this is that what you're yeah
absolutely that's that's your option you
can drink and nothing after that if you
got a story I will hear it Taylor we're
walking into a hotel room and having
someone have been waiting in there
really that's pretty cool well yeah
that's a little cringe-worthy okay I'll
take a step huh yeah I think we're just
all trying to like just weirdoes
alternate right now now this one we kind
of already talked about so I think I
know the answer my question is have you
ever hooked up with a fan but y'all
married fans so yeah for the long haul
Cheers what about before you were
married oh if you're sipping okay there
we go yeah this one you need to
collectively agree on shag marry kill
trios addition here are these three
trios okay Destiny's Child Charlie's
Angels or the Golden Girls
I mean there is no there's no tsk alayan
Blanche would take you to places you've
never been before laughs to warm and to
tinged a warmer to tingly into hot
no just marry together and if you if
you're married I think the Golden Girls
yeah I got experience on their side yeah
so you're married Golden Girls yeah yeah
and you're killing Charlie's Angels well
because they're already involved in
Destiny's Child because there's no
bootylicious Golden Girls yeah shagging
destiny shot yeah this is making me want
to drink the matter
describe your most uncomfortable run-in
with another celebrity I that's just a
drink please guys I demand you drink
[Laughter]
let's go back and talk about your hair
evolution to say you want to have long
hair
I still have long hair by the way like
more like guys in bands that have long
hair like we don't want to have to cut
our hair and Led Zeppelin be like
they've got long hair let's do it here
our hair out of rebel out of rebellion
in some form and then when you got older
to decide like short metal live or you
like we can't all have the same haircut
you guys I'm no definitely not that
common it it is just there wouldn't
metal long that's mercenary like
everyone it's representation the fact
that we are very different people
I'm a kind of a neat kind of clean and
tidy kind of person I'm a little bit OCD
you probably will never see me very
rarely out out of a pair of sneakers
okay right you know like we're just very
different and like what brings us
together
he's like shared experience the life but
then
like making in the music and meeting
like I need a guitarist
might as well be that guy man masochism
that's kind of Alexis you know okay last
one for each of you tell me something
about one of your brothers that we would
never guessed by looking at him Isaac
has had more cavities than any other
Hanson brother
really sweetie true but you know no no
no I because utiful pearly white and
he's also the best probably the best
most hygienic actually yes Zack is Zack
has his own 3d printer okay okay Taylor
has fallen off the stage more times than
any other hands but really yeah but
that's code for Taylor's the only one
who's bought off the stage I wouldn't
recommend it it's just you know what you
do you start a bad company so you can
drown your sorrows
goodbye yes thank you so much guys did
not keep score today I don't even know
what the score would be I don't know
anything guess I win I think we all win
that beer is delicious hey everybody we
are Hansen and you enjoy having beers
but we recommend that you drink
responsibly because drinking
irresponsibly is dumb so don't do it
yeah don't be dumb be smart be
responsible and
Cheers
[Music]
you